the witcher season two episode one today
what a long wait it's been for all of
you except for us yep guys look we know
a lot of people were saying to watch
nightmare of the wolf and uh we did in
chunks uh we had to do our own time with
the amount of special projects and
events that are intertwined to those
special projects i've been pretty much
in this room for like until five to six
a.m almost every day this week so just
didn't have time to sit down and make a
video for it so we just had to watch it
because we wanted to be on top of making
sure when season two came out thank you
for the recommendation that information
did seem very necessary i'm gonna do a
re-watch of it so that way i could
really appreciate the whole piece as it
is instead of just gathering information
but thank you guys anywho we are here
though for the main event season two
episode one you know what to do leave a
like toss a coin to that subscribe
button uh full length watch along so you
sync up with the time code or over at
our patreon page uh cover a bunch of
shows over there as well and lastly
thank you to the boys over at prepper
for helping us edit down these
highlights i don't know what the release
schedule is going to be like just yet
gonna need a day to rest at some point
but there'll be a time when they're a
little bit more consistent throughout
the week and we're not gonna do like a
one week at a time type of deal anyway
let's get to it
where is everybody
hello
colin is a surprisingly normal name
there's always a token normal name guy
i'm in need of logic
oh my goodness oh has he been like
dissanguinated
[Applause]
hey now
that looks bat like
not today
wow thank god they're not doing a
drastic time jump forward
oh just you wait
[Applause]
wow hardcore henry
searching for someone
oh
[Laughter]
damn wow
she's gone
you'll find her among the dead
oh [ __ ] he's there
is she alive
we won
because of her she bought us time until
the armies arrived
wasn't worth it
oh poor guy yeah
he can't
she looks so clean i know
used to seeing her covered in mud and
stuff
i sleep like [ __ ] too
there's a whole episode about it you
claim the law of surprise and got me
why
there's payment for a dad
i saved your father's life
from what your grandmother didn't want
your mother marrying her an outsider
hedgehog a freak
i'm your destiny
whatever that means you're much more
than that cirilla
we will find universe she will be your
mom we will be a family
frangilla was at the front
coordinating the north guardian attack
with the prisoner we took she has
abandoned
all rules of chaos
there's an irony at work there
he will give us everything we need
if i can have time with him
we have rules hmm yeah it's all going
out the window now man
oh yes oh yeah
my favorite neck's gonna be real sore
after sleeping on it that way oh [ __ ]
[Music]
that's our first line
what exactly is cameron
witches go during the winter there was
an attack
a long time ago when i was a boy
almost wiped us all out you can watch it
now on netflix
back on the battlefield when you saw me
and that woman before it happened yes
well
it was
it was more like a dream it's still the
future
it's what we call a premonition
oh bambi's mom
oh my god
strider
i know a great place called the prancing
pony there are no guards
there are no barking dogs either
this place never sleeps which means
there's vacancy
oh
yo
what is that boss battle
geralt huh
neverland
what the [ __ ] are you doing here you old
horse huh
put away your knife and coming out of
the cold witcher i'll tell you
everything so what's a tim burton
quality about this yeah what say you to
a hot bath to warm your frozen bones
just take it right here with us in the
room a bit of a beauty and the beast
vibe to you yeah absolutely hold up in
this castle
[Music]
oh
but of course uh
you look lovely
you'll stay yes yes be my queen yes has
he told you how he first met
no
he's not especially chatty no
he said he would be this season tell us
about your curse
in front of the girl
she's tougher than you think
it's cool seeing them together
yeah
i trashed the temple of the lion at the
spider high on goldfish mushrooms oh
this priestess
cursed me to live like this she screamed
something about
love and blood i don't remember yeah you
do and makeup on him is amazing that's
about to say uh in the little subtle
cg embellishments neverland do you have
a cat
i do in fact she's fine i'm very glad of
a company even if she's a shy wee thing
careful that's horror that's worth the
vibe yeah yeah
you know there's a little bit all these
guys in there how about we scout the
property
make sure it's secure for the night
go on geralt
we'll be all right i don't trust this
guy yeah
what a welcome sight what a what a
prisoner it's time for some era torture
are you my inquisitor or executioner a
little bit of this a little bit of that
do what you will
the white flame will cleanse us all
so now i will take
the knowledge
up your memories
[Music]
and leave you cold and helpless trapped
in the eternal darkness of your own mind
nice
oh my gosh
i know you want to scream
but it's too soon
it's too soon because i haven't even
started yet
[Music]
i will plow it somewhere
and then you will know what a scream can
really be
good for her
i can't imagine what's his name emmy
my humble apologies the mighty white
flame himself
you've broken their sacred law you've
tapped into fire magic to say his best
i'll be lauded for saving them
i'm sure they'll be most understanding
all leaders are
gonna hurry but yeah
i know what i really am you don't seem
like a monster to me monsters
are more than just horrid looks and
claws and teeth monsters are born of
deeds done
unforgivable ones i
will remember that
for life absolutely
that's
i really love that line yeah monsters
are born of deeds done
all this time i could have built a
snowman
or a snow angel at least
that was that uh the cat yeah probably
what changed you
you know for a finger park and where is
this rarest and fairest of all maidens
she's dead
how long ago
a few days
how are you not heartbroken
who says i'm not ugh what a
badass way to handle your group
what a badass way to be hung up on a
girl
i know you truly are what are you hiding
now
i need to drain the snake and hit the
silk
what the [ __ ] man just talk you sold
that
is creepy
[Music]
great now it's the grudge awesome that
is really well done holy crap
that is awesome
wow whoa
that is so cool
[Music]
what yeah
there's such a weird way i love it it
looks like they shot her at a different
frame rate or something who are you
i'm farina a friend of neverland
i'm a cat
did you like the dress i left for you
oh nice
that's why he looks so like huh yeah
okay
i'm different i'm not you whoa i am like
you
she's like the the batgirl from vhs
i like you alone in the heart like you
different
what is that effect
he hit you from the witcher
this must be our secret
until you leave
oh
what's in that kiss
i feel like the fantasy mood is way more
elevated than before yeah
it's like at the forefront of almost
every moment yeah
and it still feels so like tangible yeah
it's a really part of the environment
and
like has everything we're cutting around
too
it flies
roaches by the gate if any other me
leaves this place
right for your life what's happening
there's a brookshire in the house
what's going on
no
oh no this is bad yes your friend
clearly cares about this something's
gonna get sticky here
[Music]
oh
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like on one of those spinny rides
where you try and
get off the g-force
here i thought geralt's gonna be
oh nice damn
wow
oh no
oh my god look at her like siri
no
little manipulator no
get back to roach
[Applause]
i'm just misunderstood i don't want to
hurt you
ah
and now it's van helsing
whoa
oh cool
nice shot
ripper fruit
[Music]
oh
[Music]
carol cut her head off what are you
doing
wow
[Music]
[Music]
dude she was wildly emotionally unstable
my head had to go
oh my god
whoa
oh no way oh
it's like the reverse of the curse
[Music]
wait a minute who's that guy
you're free now
free
that is not alan tudyk no okay
but he still looks super familiar i
found her in the woods
she wasn't scared of me
and she was super hot she was a monster
no
she's misunderstood because she didn't
care
that i was cursed all those years ago
not for destroying the temple
raping the priestess
okay man
please
don't call me your [ __ ] mind man
use your sword
and this
me immortal now
do it yourself do it yourself
yeah
yeah
man
i really liked you up until like one of
your last lives just a minute ago
never doubt girls for a second i thought
girl was raw i know
hmm i'm saturated again when i
run
you run yeah i'm sorry man i doubted you
when i say hide
you i i feel like he's talking to me i'm
really sorry i know de carol i
everywhere i go people die
that's just the world that you live in
in this show look at this place
everyone's dying
facing your fear is not easy but i am
here for you
i'm a psychotherapist
oh man i love these two together it's
like really rewarding
they just compliment each other so well
yeah and uh all that build up from ca1
like the fact that they have such good
chemistry together you're leading them
to a salvation that doesn't exist
i wonder how long before they turn on
you
[Applause]
relatively soon oh no other desert okay
holy crap they're like crazy ass
harpoons
[Music]
release her
what's wrong with
you god
wow
[Music]
i just imagined him in a booth all day
just giving different rooms
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the many faces of geralt you could make
one of those posters and saw the same
picture or whatever but with grunts
all right let's talk about
all right john i learned who this man is
oh good ready for it no look at his
thumbnail look at his face
christopher's face he viewed oh is he
is he uh tormund giants bane
no
damn he's torment giant spain on game of
thrones
yeah without the beard i didn't pick it
up yeah without looking completely
different it was really difficult to
pick up
it's very true absolutely yo
we back strong
the fury
i'm waiting to see like what the defined
new kind of flavor is i always like that
with the new season of like what are
they going to do different about the way
they go about executing this cause i
haven't
read up on anything never read up on
like what the new approach is going to
be or even what people's response to
this new season has been
but for a pilot uh it's kind of like if
del toro did a messed up beauty in the b
story yeah it's a lot of what his his
whole thing looked like straight out of
beauty and the beast like it's the
makeup the castle even when he stripped
down to being a human kid yeah
absolutely
fresh face like oh no yeah it's kind of
keeping this one person locked up
in a way yeah but he's uh instead of
being like cold and reserved and keep
away he's a lot more gregarious towards
his friends
or the ones he at least welcomes in
it's still like a it's a tragedy instead
of true love saving it's
losing your love that lifts the curse
you know yeah
yeah some interesting things that happen
here
and i guess uh first episodes of seasons
of witchers involved killing attractive
women
and
yes so sad first time you see that woman
first time you see her nude
freaking
a little like spike through the chest
might that have to be the first one oh
yeah i know it's a true loss to all the
hetero men out there watching i imagine
they're naked
crap every time i imagine it there's no
big spike through her
hey for somebody out there though that's
a plus for somebody out there that's a
fetish i mean normally i'd admit it if
the camera wasn't rolling yeah yeah
right now i'm gonna say it's not
uh but damn what they did with her are
the effects
that was i i could have pinpointed
what they how they did that like this is
so they kept doing like the coolest
visuals with her and she's on the roof
on the ceiling a little little spider
crawl that she does and then
it seemed like it was most impressive
when she was in the same shot as like
cyrilla
she's like
that like sped up
motion and she has to like be able to
contort her body and not hear wait
actually i'm going to be i want to see
if she has like
some weird ass background and something
contortions
contortion actors
because uh she's actually it was in the
star of a show called monster
uh in 2017. i don't know if that's the
supernatural show or not uh let's see
here i just have to know
norwegian
i don't see any facts about her okay i
don't know it doesn't matter anymore
but
yeah the way they did her and the way
they uh
you know because like garrett's often
very uh
monster but
and cirilla this is all new for her so
she has uh she can she can be
gaslighted at worst-case scenario you
know she could be manipulated because
she'll have more of a compassionate
child-like sense towards all this she
hasn't become
her grandmother
one she hasn't witnessed the moments
that we have where i mean geralt is you
as much as he is like monster bad like
there are fair enough times where he'll
be like
this thing's not misunderstood though
yeah just probably like leave it alone
or give it like you know it came to be
yeah yeah yeah and so it seems like yeah
it's it's going to be fun to watch her
learn to trust his judgment because he
isn't you know a bloodthirsty witcher
but there's going to be i'm sure things
about compassion
it's kind of like
he's the terminator and she's john
carter yes yes
that's a good one yeah he's the
chosen one of something
for the future
and he's this
cold assassin
who is learning about emotion yeah
and uh
on this journey she has to trust him and
boy do they have good chemistry together
they really do they have fantastic
chemistry you like there's enough
differences but there's like this
understanding
towards each other the oh yeah the guy
who plays nibbling he's like he's great
in game of thrones but
i really loved his performance here that
makeup was oh yeah and so he has really
insane makeup yeah i mean across this
episode i think they had a really
beautiful blend of of physical practical
effects and cg embellishments and i mean
between verena and
neville and like they really showcased
some pretty breathtaking stuff and yeah
like just the way the lips move on his
whole situation and then just yeah the
way
uh it all really comes together to sell
that effect and like you do really
endear to him just in that form to the
point where when he's back in human form
it's almost like weird you know and then
he's at that last line to reveal why he
was cursing like yeah you deserve to die
and yeah you be and you feel i mean
it's a blow because you're like what the
hell man i was sold on you were an all
right guy i was really yeah and i was
like looking forward to like oh man
maybe he'll you know be checked in with
periodically or maybe this will be
somebody in geralt's you know little
life here that we can expect to see in
the future and then yeah by the end
you're like oh god no please get rid of
this guy
like i think it's you they it's very
smart the way they played it because
yeah they do really endear you to him up
until that point and that's
i'm curious to know what everyone's
opinion is on the handling of that
character but it is very indicative of
like oh yeah some of the people who do
stuff like that can be the most charming
and convincing
people you know and people who can
easily elicit sympathy and easily uh
kind of deflect from the true darkness
within them
yeah because he has your feelings it's
it's a cool
writing technique they did with him
because
this show has you like go should i trust
him then you start to feel very
sympathetic and pitiful towards him
and
he his character kind of plays into that
but seems to be like no don't feel sorry
for me that's okay yeah
and then at the end he's pretty much
begging for pity yeah and you're like no
yeah yeah that's for you and i and i
love the he's a great actor though it
really is a fantastic actor and i mean
it's not easy i would imagine to take on
a role like that that has such a
despicable core and i really love the
sort of
heartbreaking grayness by the end of it
because you know especially when uh
verena like goes full bat you know you
kind of realize okay like you know
there are points during the actual fight
where i was like i don't know maybe it
will turn out that you know she just
like backed into a corner and getting
defensive or whatever but like there is
this interesting web where like she is
this monster stricken with this
uncontrollable bloodlust or whatever
that strikes and even though he's trying
to mitigate it you know with letting her
feed off of him it's still something
neither of them can control you you do
feel kind of bad for varina like you do
feel
bad for her and i like that she's even
like you know if you run i cannot help
myself from trying to get on top you
know and i bought that she didn't want
to hurt siri
and uh and so
yeah it almost seems like she in a
tragic way is also kind of caught up in
his web too yeah yeah
just so funny to hear about like that
line too with nipple and how he says
that line about
monsters or not just i said during the
reaction i would never forget this and i
have forgotten how it goes down
is done
something like that
yeah because they're not just made of
claws and
whatever yeah they're not scary monsters
are not
what they are by appearance they
monsters are
defined by what they do
and
that's what made him a monster
that's what he did it's interesting
uh and yeah she very much deserved what
happened to him versus the story tells
geralt yeah
i i like uh i like the the setting a lot
i love the dark fantasy tone that this
strikes where it has this
um burton del toro-esque like
nightmare gothic one i was getting there
i was going to find the gothic horror
i almost had it
give me like 10 minutes and i would find
the word you're so jiggy just let me
ramble over for like 10 minutes and i'll
find the word gothic
horror no no it's like tim burton
guillermo del toro kind of you know
already found it oh i pulled it up from
the mines
yeah
speak friend and enter
that's a it's a book franchise i'm just
never going to read but man do i love
that movie
solid adaptation
uh
yeah
so uh i i thought we're talking about
the
yeah the gothic aesthetics were
beautiful to behold because you know you
do suspect there's a i mean it has a
very striking
it's very contained it's like an
isolated episode of this mansion uh or
this palace of sorts and i like that it
starts off with the deaths to imply like
oh okay okay was it him who killed them
or
the cat
and what's the true nature of her like i
like that they left that a mystery for
so like you get a clue from the you know
little
sigil at the front but yeah they leave
it such a mystery but then they also uh
have her first scene and be like her
first actual dialogue scene with sorella
where it does have you puts you in
cirilla's perspective to make you
question your main character who you've
trusted all these episodes yeah yeah
yeah yeah i do see some differences i
can't quite pinpoint it yet i imagine
with a few more episodes i i'd be able
to more clearly define some differences
and how they're
how they're capturing it i think a big
difference is the fact that it's just
linear now versus
timelines
that you have to kind of mess around
with
uh but man
henry cavill just slips into this role
so seamlessly
seriously
i love i love everything he he's doing
man i just see geralt he's flawless you
know there's another
there's another movie where he has to
resist against the power of some very
sound wave ring vibrations right
name that movie it's my favorite dceu
film batman v superman dawn of justice
the ultimate edition
and the theatrical no the theatrical cut
is way better i'm gonna go on the record
and just say that's the definitive cut
because i don't think that movies should
be easy to uh interpret in basic plot
and uh you know character
well yes
i couldn't help but flash that because
he did have to do that but the fight is
good here
everything was very uh
like
it had this interesting build
to it
and i think yennefer and the story of
like i didn't expect that like oh
jennifer franjilla kind of locked off
together and
i want to see more of because right now
everything's kind of there's some
interesting dialogue there but it was uh
imaginable getting further more
because i remember on the finale we were
like i hope that pays off a little bit
more of you know frangilla
being like enjoying the dark side yeah
and i didn't think it would and then now
we're here i don't think it would so
soon like like starts to have the plot
of that and then from jillian for being
able to have more scenes of battle of
ideologies i think would be really
fascinating to
uh delve into so i really enjoy that
quite a bit to saya is
so emotional totally way more emotional
than ever before she misses her piglet
and she seems so human right yeah she
really does
seems yeah grief-stricken you are
different yeah cause last season you
were like queen stoic never letting on
your full emotional like uh feeling
toward anybody i think that's a big
difference is because uh like as the
witcher season one progressed it stopped
feeling as cold with the characters and
not that i actually didn't mind that i
thought that was a good choice well then
that's what made like the compliment
effect of jennifer in her introductory
episode feels so strong so she's so
emotional or the other there's a there's
a bit of a cold openness about the other
characters i think it's used well yeah
yeah but uh this one like everyone is is
exceptionally like the emotions are very
front and center on all accounts yeah
it's not just even even when you get a
character like nivalin who's uh has a
lot of information to drop he didn't
shut the [ __ ] up he's got all this
information uh it's all very emotional
like it's keeping the emotions on the
surface too
is important uh for especially for a
show like this which has such vast world
building
and you know nightmare the wolf very
necessary because that one would have
been like what the hell was he talking
about
one [ __ ] scene i feel like i need a
whole movie just to explain this piece
of dialogue
[Laughter]
we're gonna get to like uh oh my god
this here
uh uh oh oh uh oh come on i know
uh vesemir that's a mirror yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's the mirror yeah you
gotta get to the best of mirror and then
um wait the guy yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah yeah i just think i was talking
about no i was making sure that we
weren't talking about the place the the
place where the witchers go to be alone
their man cave
chicago chicago the chicago witchers
starting lineup for your chicago witches
here at wrigley field or whatever
chicago place
good stuff man got me real you know the
last last thing just last thing
this got me really excited because there
was no yas gear so i'm like when is he
coming because that's going to be a fun
moment when he finally shows back yes we
have all the episodes i could just go
like scrub them and find it yeah
see what happens in fact everyone
comment and spoil that for us please
don't do that i hope he comes back i
hope he i mean he was in the you know
red carpet stuff so i assumed
i could just be uh we invited you just
here for moral support yeah that would
be a good way to throw people off
honestly
yeah you know and then upset i guess
upset them later
get ready for the backlash
coming from me
if there's no yes i i believe i caught
the rotten tomato score this season it
was pretty high
it's a lot higher than the first c i
feel like the first season has has
really appreciated in people's enjoyment
and and love of it and i feel it's just
fans yelled at them
yeah they wonder well it doesn't make
you wonder and i mean
because i really liked the first season
and i wonder too when you see some of
those like critical reviews of shows
it's like well did they only get the
first three episodes there's some stuff
that you might not get really fully but
i think critics got like six episodes
okay that's a lot but yeah yeah i was
happily surprised to be like okay
critics are way more uh uh positive
about this it's a solid start and uh
then they do plant the seed though with
arena being like don't trust this guy
so you know playing with toying with
that doubt
yeah man
talk cast some doubt on your witcher
doubt
just to say a check on imdb dude you
know i've always thought to say i was
all right man that's right yeah
no she's a september girl
september girl she was in the descent
look at that hey
december
it's a good time to be here to be born
yeah that's virgo season yeah or the
other one after all right yeah
[Laughter]
give a shitless
all right guys
well that was fun that was a blasty
blast of a time quite happy with your
fan leave your thoughts down below
of the whole series to encourage us not
to read your accomplishment yeah all
right that like button
and hey let's do a page
david the gandy david gandy i've got a
mission for you buddy i know it's
christmas time now is the perfect time
to request a witcher costume i want to
see next halloween you dressed as geralt
cause you know you got the sort of stoic
vibes already but you got that
compassion that underlies all that so
you decked out all leather studs and all
you know big old sword full on wig i
feel like you could unlock the true
badass
hidden within you i mean you're already
a martial artist toss a coin to your
gandhi and that's what i want uh for
next christmas this christmas so this
works in both of our favors you get some
nice duds i get to see you in a cosplay
then we can you know all dress up i'll
sing a little tune about you and then
you know greg can get some creature
makeup on you can fight each other make
like a a little web sketch it's gonna go
super viral everyone's gonna love it and
then we're gonna get invited to be part
of season three it's gonna be amazing
david you've got your marching orders
and uh hope you're doing well as well
because it's the holidays and it's time
to feel nice and warm and cheery and you
make me feel nice and warm and cheery so
uh much love david gandy peace be with
you
that was the return of the king of shout
outs they've got three more endings
though
[Music]
you